reunimos a 7 Drag Queens yo soy una drag
Queen Yo soy una drag Queen soy una
soy una drag Queen una de ellas miente
Quién es el impostor
genial sí dicen A qué se dedican primero
tú está bien pero aquí te refieres
creo contenido para tiktok y también
para Instagram Ah me encuentran como
yoshidrack y mi patio trasero en casa
eso es algo un poco privado
pensé que los demás sospecharían Porque
no luzco como la típica drag Queen saben
creo que mi razón como dirían los
franceses son los niños dirijo de una
organización llamada drag Queen Story
Hour les leemos en bibliotecas y museos
y es increíble es algo que me fascina
diría que lo mío es ser un drag Queen
conceptual me gusta crear presentaciones
basadas en una idea y cuando Pensé en un
estilo compré un palo saltador y preparé
un número en tacones de verdad tengo un
palo saltador está allá atrás pues en mi
caso trabajo como Dj pero siempre me
visto así Cada vez que lo amo
siempre Ahora
hablo del remix te lo enviaré después
que son Djs pero lucen más demacradas
por pasar tanto tiempo de pie son como
se le ve bastante elegante Y puede que
hasta demasiado arreglada Y es más que
obvio que recién compró esas plataformas
bueno en mi caso yo soy una look Queen
Sí con gracia todavía aún así pero
también amo el cosplay y me inspiro los
videojuegos y las pelis soy de Kansas
tengo poco tiempo en Los Ángeles
bienvenidos mi primera presentación como
drag fue en hamburger mary's ahora Widow
bondio es como mi madre Track Así que sí
es increíble sin duda
Pero pueden verme todos los martes en
rocos en West Hollywood estoy trabajando
allí ahora
dijo que trabajen rocos Pero los que
somos de Los Ángeles sabemos que llegar
a presentarse en West Hollywood cuesta
bastante Ah yo también creo looks soy
maquillista además de ser drag y hago
todo por mi Así que diseño mis atuendos
mis pelucas pero me enfoco más en el
maquillaje
fue una publicidad para mi show es
cierto hice un show en ayer también
estaban otras drag Queens y Fue genial
Sí Por qué preguntas tanto
a todos nosotras no solo contigo y estás
preguntando mucho lo sé que tengo muchas
preguntas soy muy curiosa quién sabe
cómo se llama
garnet Sí también ella
quería controlar la conversación y creo
que eso es algo que solo haría el
impostor
sus Converse y toda esa historia del
patio no me convencieron del todo
si está tan tranquila y casi no habla
entonces me parece sospechosa
tenemos un empate entre
pico
Pero qué sorpresa
quisiera pedirle a ambas que por favor
se volteen y cubran sus oídos el resto
por favor acérquense tendrán 30 segundos
para llegar a un acuerdo Ella parece muy
energética y su personalidad es aún pero
siento que oculta algo quién crees
muy bien Es hora de regresar a sus
lugares
la persona eliminada en esta ronda es
[Risas]
que probablemente le di la impresión de
ser muy
pero no tengo la culpa de ser tan
carismática
todos que yo era el impostor
no voté por ti yo tampoco voté por ti y
yo tampoco
no es así puedo decirte por quien voté
Samantha puedo preguntar Claro sí
dijiste que te presentasen rojo los
martes si empecé allí hacen
se llama La dama y el vagabundo de hecho
un chico es protagonista y actuó con él
durante todo el show hasta nos besamos
yo Les recomiendo a todos que vengan a
vernos y admirarme de pies a cabeza de
acuerdo y cómo entraste en roco Sé que
es difícil trabajar allí si no tienes
experiencia lo cierto Es que soy muy
buena amiga de la cancha extraña de
hecho nos conocimos cuando llegué aquí y
ellos se presentan rocos todo el tiempo
así que tuve mucha suerte de conseguir
empleo tan rápido después de mudarme
está bien no hay problema
Será mejor que te calmes no salgas
haciéndote La inocente vela cuál era su
nombre Bueno tú eres la menor de
nosotras y también me pareció entender
que era Queen no así que Cómo
describirías Qué tipo de traje
términos como Bio Queen son innecesarios
además me identifico como trans Así que
estos términos son maravilloso
realmente luces estupenda increíble
pero una versión femenina que me encanta
Oigan les importa si pregunto cómo se
iniciaron en esto Cómo se hicieron drag
Queens Cuando empecé en tiktok me puse
una peluca y empecé a bailar Y a partir
de ese momento todos empezó a dar y aquí
estoy Es genial para mí el drag implique
reclamar muchos de lo que he perdido
niño debido a la operación sexual así
como la homofobia ya sea internalizada o
no el drag me permite recuperar esa vida
que perdí y celebrarla en el presente de
manera auténtica y se siente muy bien
pero qué respuesta tan profunda
son dos historias completamente
diferentes pensé que la razón por la que
ella mencionó la de su patio es porque
técnicamente no se presenta en un
escenario con audiencia pero no lo sé
aún sospecho de Sí pues yo empecé
vistiéndome como un Club Club y luego
solo quise probar más yo me considero un
artista no diría que soy una Sí sí
porque eso me encerraría en una caja
como esta Exacto bien cuando salí del
clóset conocía rupaul's drag Race Así
que empecé a verla y dije Oh esto es
genial quiero intentarlo también me
inicié en el Track después de enamorarme
del maquillaje YouTube de acné Severo
durante la escuela y el maquillaje me
ayudó a lidiar con eso mi madre es
alguien que siempre Tuvo una gran
colección de maquillaje y con el tiempo
me empezó a gustar hasta que empecé a
hacer maquillaje Drake en mi cuarto a la
una de la mañana y yo no quería que mi
familia supiera Pero ellos son muy
comprensivos y me dijeron que lo hiciera
Y ahora hasta me llevan a las marchas
del orgullo y demás
historia me vamos
mencionó muchos nombres de rupaul's Drag
Race como que guido bondio es tu madre
eso no es creíble
es ella fuera
siento que estaba vomitando frases al
azar solo para salvarse
voté por voz porque pensé que todos
votarían por ella una vez más
les dije que soy una drag Queen real
ustedes pierden yo no Yo estoy un poco
molesta porque esto es lo que hago Para
ganarme la vida mírenme Hasta tengo
puestos unos pechos falsos si creen que
el impostor sigue en el grupo y quieren
continuar con el juego levanten la mano
Y eso es todo
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
él es una ta ta ta ta increíble vamos Dj
casi chica
bien Vamos vamos excelente
eso no cabe duda
[Música]
usando Converse alerta de impostor me
parece un poco poco sospechoso
volví a votar por Tokio voz porque no
creo que sea nadie más
pensé que teníamos
la verdad es que estoy molesta pero bien
como sea que saquen a la competencia y
quedamos cuatro el top 4 si creen que el
impostor sigue en el grupo y quieren
continuar con el juego levanten la mano
[Música]
la mayoría tiene que votar quién creías
que era el impostor yo sobre los que era
Samanta Sí también
pensé que era vos pero no lo sé quiero
más dinero para mí
me gusta como suena eso no quiero
acusarte De nada Pero has estado muy
callada hasta ahora
digo Soy bastante joven y yo no estoy
acostumbrada a hablar sobre el drag no
hago mucho solo voy a la escuela ella
está dijiste que no te identificas como
un artista drax sino como una coma lo
hago porque como persona no binaria me
gusta más expresar mi feminidad mediante
el drag bien Estoy de acuerdo con
dividir el premio Yo también lo estoy
Lamento si Sonia algo codiciosa
Si las luces se vuelven rojas significa
que el impostor sigue en el juego y
perdieron si se vuelven verdes significa
que sacaron el impostor y ganaron listas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
lo hicimos bien
por favor que el impostor de verle su
identidad a la cuenta de 3 2
no debería haber mencionado a rocos
solo pensaba tengo que decir el nombre
de un bar ahora y tengo que pensar en un
show y yo cuando dijiste rojo
Bueno en realidad yo trabajo como
influencer y maquillador así que tomamos
de tener muchos amigos que son drag
Queens la granja es una amiga muy
cercana pues ya nomás este
sabes
qué belleza qué te llevas de esta
experiencia bueno no dinero saben pero
si me llevo la confirmación de que puedo
hacer todo lo que me proponga para ser
honesta siempre digo que para hacer drag
Queen solo necesitas querer ser Fabulosa
el drag realmente me ha enseñado mucho
más acerca de mi género y cuando Sugar
mencionó las distintas partes de su
identidad pude ver como el drag le ayudó
sintió una conexión y también noté su
autenticidad Espero que más personas
puedan ver que existen más de un tipo de
Track y que cualquier persona puede
dedicarse a ello sí
[Música]